durch meine liebe freuen und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einem kleinen mini
blog und zwar fahre ich gerade zum let's
play pokal beziehungsweise waschen aber
ich hatte die kamera vergessen und da
muss ich noch mal so einen umweg fahren
jedenfalls werde ich dort mitspielen ich
kann zwar noch kein pokern aber ich
hoffe das werde ich das ein bisschen
lernen und dann würde ich sagen die mich
euch damit in und ob wir das ja wissen
was filmen kann und er wird erst mal
weniger wird schöne grüße an die
community
heute
was ist deine taktik heute diana sind
hier in der region gekommen
hallo ihr mich ist alles nacheinander
abgespielt
das wusste ich natürlich hier passiert
alles nach abgespielt auf hochtouren
gearbeitet
hallo hallo mein name ist lucas vom
kanal hd und ich erzähle euch heute sie
belügen und allgemein über meine arbeit
habe jetzt hier was ihr auch was
und hier sind spricht denkt und damit
kann ich dann nachher kommunizieren mit
der erde
wenn ich im weltraum bin wir sind dem
hochhaus und startete die skyline das
ist nicht meine hand die sich das spiel
wir haben hier nachher den tisch hier
wird schon fleißig gefilmt da steht der
kev hallo und ich werde nachher genau
hier wissen das ist platz sieben setzte
ihr coach uwe lohse jedenfalls sind
hierzu scanner drin und wenn ich hier
eine karte drauf legen dann ist es so
dass ich dachte man früher das hier so
kameras drin sind allerdings ist das
hier ein scanner und zwar wenn ich die
karte hier hinlege wird von unten
gescannt wasser drin ist und wir haben
schon so ein paar dinge hier kommt es
nicht aber das zeigen jetzt geben wir
das hier mal dem wand sarrazin
das wird aufgenommen
hallo wo zitrone
lasst mich doch jetzt einmal nach unten
und dann wird ja freunde gerade alles
gibt also wie wir quasi dar einlaufen
werden
die zehnte ausgabe
deswegen haben uns gedacht dürfen wir
reden
das jubiläums ausgabe ist steigern wie
die stimmung dadurch dass wir uns alle
ist es einfach mal
wir haben hier alle mit am start der
leder der greift sie muss durch da vorne
seht ihr das ganze was ihr uns gerade
weht wenn ihr gerade im live stream sei
kompliziert formuliert aber wir befinden
uns jetzt gerade
und es ist sehr viel weil man was ein
könig so macht oder ritter
gleich die kleine karte homann
o
irgendwie auf den salon spiel ich
reingegangen bin mit einem full house
und ich hab verloren
gegen eine beauty youtube-videos der im
holz alles wird jeweils ich bin raus und
ladenketten full house
aber jana hat den höheren für haustiere
hatten den gleichen schulhaus quasi nur
passen und ich hatte den buben war
traurig freuen habe ich danke euch
ob ich in welchem fick dich diana was
sagst du dazu dass sich das erdbeben
hatte ich dachte immer ein full house
hatte das wohl sagen bei mir läuft
ok jetzt hast du alle kartoffelchips
nicht einen einzigen anderen chips mich
so jetzt im mittelfeld so stark ich
glaube an dich
so sieht übrigens das ganze studio aus
wenn das ganze in betrieb ist hier
stehen die riesigen kameras hier vorne
wird jetzt gebaut von ganzen usern hier
ist der salon straße wald und ich jetzt
mal kurz raus weil die haben zu 100
sekunden pause aber ich kann gar nicht
aus nicht brauche monika frische luft
und die spanier gericht hat gesagt ich
muss ihm halt ein bisschen komisch
klingen gekreuzt und erteilt kann nur
ich meine videos an rechnen aber das wie
gesagt ich mir gekauft habe wenn ich
noch mehr einkaufen hier zeigen
hardy irgendwie und oliver pohl vom
tisch geflogen also weil beide teams
sind allerdings maps ganze ding
wahrscheinlich bleibt irgendwie beiden
bieter oder thierry doubai und habe
selber gesehen
ich fand's cool war es eine spannende
runde und am ende januar
nein
freunde der live vom 1
so stark hätte ich vorher nicht gedacht
dafür dass du mir gestern gesagt hast
dass du dir gestern die ersten videos
angeschaut ist dazu wie bist du noch mal
rausgeflogen jetzt genau der sturm ihr
habt für schuhe 90 prozent aller aktien
ist der extreme alicante und ich gehe
jetzt nur noch um absolut figur
irgendwie war der moment plakaten von
mittelmäßigen stellen 3000 davon
vielleicht setze mich wieder zur rettung
war die richtige entscheidung nach wert
verloren
der poker hat nicht mittels ausgerissen
mit dem tod eiskalt hat er mich dazu
betrieben einen letzten chips zu setzen
ja aber er ist ein netter typ und
verzeichne botschaft direkt an oliver
wenn das ihr solltet auch botschafterin
oliver ich sollten wir jemals wieder
nebeneinander sitzen dann lasse ich mich
und einsprüchen nicht beeindrucken ja
ich ziehe mein ding trotzdem durch und
da ist es sehr gutes spiel
damit auch unter schock ich mich dann
kommt auf 8 schon verdient ja von allen
verabschieden
aber jeder kommt einfach mal zu zwingen
er weiss denkt an mit dem longboard
fahren versteht den longbond
führerschein
bitte was der kanzler der ganze schon
richtig wir sind also gehört von der
kirche versagen wandel verlaufen jetzt
zu der location wo jetzt die after show
party ist wo wir natürlich gebühr ich
denke winterfeier werden vom netzwerk
broker sehen den herrn hoffen dass
wartet hier von diesem video blog von
mir zum netzwerk poker ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen ist es getan hat würde ich
mich über eine bewertung von ich saß an
der bearbeitung der recht lange
eventuell werde ich war's in zukunft
wirklich mal wieder öfter machen
dieses ganze blocks ab jetzt gesehen in
den letzten sechs tagen haben auch schon
wieder vier live videos ich weiß nicht
vielleicht ist euch auch zu viel ich
habe mich damit höher schon für ihn
spricht dass ich als gamer immer recht
real live videos hochladen
vielleicht gefällt so ja und dann sehen
wir uns irgendwann anders wieder